he always puts 100 into characters how
many times have you watched a johnny
depp film and not recognized the actor
at all depp is famous for his character
and physical transformations and we're
taking a look at just how intense and
painful they could be i didn't care if i
knew if i was capable or not yeah i
wanted to try number one
let's jump down the rabbit hole in my
mind he's mad and thanks to the
extensive makeup prosthetics and a bit
of cg he looked it too when johnny depp
was prepping for production he and tim
burton both made sketches of what they
felt the character should look like and
then makeup artist joel harlow took the
images and created them using johnny's
face as a canvas emphasizing his natural
features both with makeup and with cgi
in post-production to enlarge in those
eyes then there was the hot thick
electric orange yak hair wig just kind
of you know had its own personality and
the brightly painted contact lenses that
brought those haunting eyes to the
screen and had one of them painted just
ever so slightly off and we can't talk
about this transformation without
mentioning the incredibly decorated
costume featuring all the tools he'd
need as a hatter on a regular basis he
was so unrecognizable number two
then he sailed on the high seas before
depp went to the ocean he went a bit
method and read his lines in the
sweltering heat of asana so he could tap
into that overheated intense feeling
mindset the heat was very important for
me you know the idea of
yeah sweltering heat and once he got to
set and in makeup it was obvious this
role was made for him and he said
that's it yeah you know he got it
immediately on top of all the hours of
makeup dirtifying him and adding a red
sword that would actually grow in size
over the course of the films the actor
had to sit through the beard braiding
and having his heavy sweat inducing wig
applied it was trying at times but
we got through it you know as gracefully
as possible and as dignified as possible
number three
we've got to talk about those teeth
diving into production for dead man's
chest man there was a whole lot of
makeup once more with a special emphasis
on the darkness around his eyes which
was inspired by the fact that it's a
method used by people trying to protect
their eyes from harsh light as for those
teeth well johnny really committed to
this one i just sort of went to the
dentist and he bonded him would these be
permanent
nope all it would take was a trip to the
dentist and speaking of permanent
changes the second pirates movie saw the
makeup team using a kind of
semi-permanent glue to help keep the
braids intact rather than the wires and
paper clips they used in the first film
to keep those braids stiff
number four
a chocolate river count us in for
someone surrounded by so much candy
johnny depp has shockingly pristine
pearly white says willy wonka thank you
movie magic the real struggle for depp
was the fact that he had to keep his
face in unusual positions to keep those
teeth in sight at all times
okay then let's move along
the sad story behind this is the fact
that it represents the trauma that his
character dealt with from his father in
the film a dentist who was also abusive
to make it all just a bit tougher depp
wore deeply colored purple contact
lenses which are never a fun time
number five
in the wizarding world you can be
anything you imagine and depp did a lot
of imagining before he even stepped foot
on set to play gellert grindelwald then
he spent hours collaborating with the
whole team and then dove right into the
transformation going so far as to
actually cut and dye his hair do you
think you can hold me
immediately after filming while he was
still on set depp had his hair dyed back
again the buzz cut he wasn't able to
hide so easily though and would it
really be a johnny depp character if
there weren't painful creepiest heck
contact lenses involved oh and how many
hours are we guessing he spent sitting
in the makeup chair to have his hair
perfectly quaffed number six
if you're gonna be a demon barber of
fleet street you've gotta commit and we
aren't surprised that johnny did both he
and helena bonham carter went through
major makeup treatments heavy white
makeup to make them pale and dark makeup
to make them look underrested and
overworked his sinister style came
across and supported just how tragic his
character's past was
number seven
looks are one thing singing that's a
whole other can of worms that's pretty
weird
a major part of playing this role was
being able to sing sorry we should say
being able to sing this particularly
tricky score when asked about how we
felt about the singing aspect depp was
pretty up front i wasn't sure if i'd be
able to sing
you know any of it it was a trying
experience causing the actors some real
anguish and attempt to transform into
this musical barber i ran out of air
about five minutes ago just pass out bam
thankfully lessons helped him prepare to
embody the role and anyone who's seen
the performance knows he absolutely
succeeded number eight
this isn't the fairy tale you think it
is and neither was depp's costume as the
wolf in the live action into the woods
it's kind of a joy to approach even
though it's incredibly daunting when he
first imagined the character it looked
pretty much like what we see on screen a
wild zoot suit featuring fedora and cat
chain however the costume could be
pretty annoying when it came to the very
long nails that made it difficult to
simply exist and terrifyingly long sharp
teeth
number nine
since their hands really aren't so
practical to have at the end of the day
depp learned that the hard way but these
epic costumes and prosthetics and makeup
didn't go unnoticed since the film was
nominated for and won multiple design
awards to prepare for the part depp had
a very clear vision i watched a lot of
charlie chaplin movies then when it came
time to film he spent a whopping two
hours prepping beforehand because of the
extensive makeup and prosthetics
application then there was the issue of
the skin-tight suit that was hot to
begin with filming under the harsh
florida sun it was a recipe for disaster
depp was kitted out with a cooling
element inside the costume but it didn't
actually work out in the end oh and the
scissor hands well joanie had a practice
pair to use at home early on the blades
on the glove hands were plastic the
actor learned very quickly just how
frustrating they could be to work with
just like being
i guess how it must feel to be sort of
handicapped the real blades came out
when the cameras started rolling though
and those blades could seriously cut
number 10
it's vampire time depp approached his
old pal tim burton eager to make some
movie magic we should do a vampire movie
together like a real vampire movie where
the vampire looks like a vampire looking
like a vampire isn't always the most
comfortable process though but the
makeup was essential nothing really
happens until the makeup goes on depp
was just as collaborative on this one as
he'd been on other projects when i'm
doing a makeup with johnny i'm doing a
makeup with johnny the actor's creepy
looking vampire style was all thanks to
a prosthetic nose bridge pointy ear
prosthetics and a face covered in pale
and dramatic makeup embodying barnabas
collins also involved elongated finger
prosthetics when the fingers are on him
they're him and insanely fierce looking
vampire fangs and of course an epic
outfit i found the character on a whole
other level once the wardrobe came into
play
[Music]
johnny depp started out each day with a
clean canvas a fresh shave was followed
by hours of hiding all his own hair
painting a skull cap and then the
application of his character's hair
after all those hours the fun continued
as depp endured a whole lot of heavy
makeup being applied all over his head
and face that airbrush is no joke oh and
just to add a bit more torture there
were more painful contact lenses
number 12.
the movie might not have gotten the best
of reviews but this transformation is
remarkable depp felt the need to go
absolutely extreme with this part so he
underwent the hair treatment and the
makeup detailing all for the sake of
embodying this shady con man for me as
an actor it was challenging in terms of
playing a character who could be you
know somewhat dubious but depp has never
been one to walk away from a challenge
number 13.
this was a serious look johnny depp's
long time makeup artist joel harlow said
out of every movie i've ever done this
movie has more makeup in it and more
different types of makeup in it than
anything else and a whole lot of it was
just for depp i said it's me man it's me
the full face of heavy cake mud-like
black and white makeup was far from
enjoyable and to make it all worse he
spent a whopping two hours having it
applied each day however the actor tried
to make the situation a bit easier for
himself saying sometimes i decided to
wear at home to save time in the morning
it wasn't comfortable and it looked
funny but it was worth it i think oh and
we haven't even gotten into the seven
prosthetics that were applied to his
face and four applied to his body then
perhaps the most difficult and frankly
creepy aspect of all the crow affixed to
his head to keep the bird in place a
painful vacu-form skull cap leveled up
with some nylon thread bolts was made
for depth to wear under the real wig so
that way the bird could be attached
securely through the bolts
all we can think is how
number fourteen
the pain didn't stop there though the
lone ranger also saw depp playing a more
aged version of his character which was
made possible by what's called full
upper body aging a technique that's
usually avoided because of how complex
time consuming and uncomfortable it is
the actor endured a full arm and torso
aging treatment that included 17
overlapping prosthetics some of which
even had hair pre-punched in them not
only did depp wear one uncomfortable
pair of contact lenses for this one he
went in for double the trouble this
really did help the aging leaving him
with droopy and watery eyes on set
number 15.
we're throwing way back to the 90s with
this one even in the early days before
depp grew to be one of the most famous
actors in the world he committed to
total transformations
how long have you been doing this
since i was a kid but in this particular
film it was a bit odd that his face was
completely slathered in white makeup
since the movie was done in black and
white anyway beyond that depp was also
getting used to restrictive dresses and
wearing heels like a champ
johnny depp is wickedly talented when it
comes to embodying all these fantastical
characters but it does come at a cost
and depp has proved time and time again
he is willing to pay for it which
transformation do you think would be the
most painful